well greetings thank you for being here
whether you are a regular or the
algorithm brought you our way and an
especially warm welcome if this is your
first time with us Adventist or
otherwise so my question of the
night
maybe according to
scripture what is the mission of the
Christian
Church according to scripture what is
the mission of the Christian
church if you are new to this platform
you might be wondering what answering
adventism is all about and why does such
a thing need to even exist you don't see
answering Baptists answering
Presbyterians Etc and these are great
questions Central to the mission of this
platform is to equip as many Christians
as possible to reach as many Seventh Day
Adventist as possible with the gospel in
order to do such one must understand
that Seventh Day adventism brings with
it a novel worldview a worldview that is
not shared by Christians I talk about
this a lot around here and for a good
reason as I've shown many times it is
their unique worldview that informs all
of Seventh Adventist theology that would
include their theology around the church
what is called ecclesiology which is
what we're going to be getting into
tonight if you are a Christian and you
interact with the Seventh Day Adventist
there is a good chance that you will be
treated terribly uh including them
putting uh you know out the vibe that
you're both Christians on the same team
Etc however what must be understood is
that while the majority of Adventists
are sincere well-meaning people the
claims made by individual Adventists do
not always reflect the organization's
official claims statements and beliefs
this platform is about examining
organizational matters not every
individual Adventist in the world which
is why tonight we're going to be
exploring whether or not 7th day
adventism as a church is united with the
Christian Church sharing in the same
Mission and message or if there's
actually a fundamental divide on these
core issues with me to discuss tonight
is my friend and Pastor Jeremiah nortier
from 125 Church in Jonesboro Arkansas
also we're going to be assisted by SDA
president Ted Wilson as he shares with
us some uh Adventist distinctives when
it comes to their proposed identity as
God's last day
Remnant but before getting into it if
you like what we are doing here please
consider partnering with us at answering
adventism tocom this ministry is a
viewer supported effort that is only
made possible by the generosity and
support of our YouTube members as well
as our website Partners it is you who
makes it possible for us to have the
impact that we are seeing which is more
and more Christians are getting equipped
and more and more Adventists are being
reached with the true Christ and his
gospel so so if you'd like to take part
in that and see it grow please consider
joining us the link to do so is in the
description box down below thank you so
much for your
support brother thank you so much for
being here thanks for having me on again
is this number three I know we talked
about the the Heavenly Trio maybe a year
or so ago that that's correct this is
actually number four we talked we talked
about um the the parall between
adventism and the Church of Christ we
talked about the Heavenly Trio and then
you were here with Dr Boyce to talk
about restorationism versus Reformation
the difference between the two that was
an excellent episode I always learned
something from Dr boy every time I I
listen to him I know I I love him he he
caused so many Adventists to melt down
because of his Anglo Catholicism um
which was rather interesting we've seen
a lot of of uh feedback regarding him
and his uh his handling of scripture but
nevertheless I'll be curious tonight to
hear your pastoral insight as we look at
some claims from the SDA church and
listen to their president talk about
their fundamental beliefs specifically
fundamental belief number 13 I'll be
curious to hear your pastoral insights
but along the way I also hope to be able
to leave not just the audience with a
better understanding on this issue but
also you as a pastor so I will be
connecting some dots along the way
helping to put some skin on the bones if
you will sound good yes absolutely all
right so to start though let's do a
couple ice breakers here to set the
stage what is your answer as a pastor to
the question of the night according to
scripture what is the mission of the
Christian church so there's two passages
in mind Ephesians 4 and Matthew 28 the
primary mission for the Ecclesia the
church is to equip the Saints for the
good work of ministry so that's primary
Saints or church are for the Saints not
the ANS okay people don't understand
that they gear their services and their
their liturgy really their lack thereof
for goats and it's like look this is for
the Saints this is for the edification
we get a taste of Heaven do people get
saved in the midst absolutely but the
mission of the church is to equip the
Saints for the good work so that the
Saints can be sent out into world into
the world to fulfill the Great
Commission to go and baptize in The
Sovereign Triune name and to learn all
of what Christ CHR has told us to do so
that would answer it that way miles amen
um one thing here sorry I'm trying to
get one thing set up that um is broken
on my end there we go I love Baptists
and their uh you guys have the the best
sort of like uh I don't know what that's
formally called but the like you said
it's for the Saints not the
ants I love that some love to our
Baptist world over here for sure we're
going to talk a little bit about um um
we're going to talk a little bit about
um well the differences between Baptists
Presbyterians Etc a little bit later but
one other thing that I I want to point
out here um is specifically Luke chapter
24 you mentioned Matthew 28 and this is
somewhat of a parallel um but there's a
lot we could look at on this obviously
but my mind goes to the taale end of
Luke 24 after his resurrection the Lord
Jesus is with his disciples he's about
to ascend and take his throne but before
doing so he leaves them with the
Christian Mission notice folks he says
then he said to them these are my words
that I spoke to you while I was still
with you that everything written about
me in the law of Moses and the prophets
and the Psalms must be
fulfilled then he opened their minds to
understand the scriptures and said to
them thus it is written that the Christ
should suffer on the third day rise from
the dead or and on the third day rise
from the dead and that repentance for
the Forgiveness of sins should be
proclaimed in the name to All Nations
beginning W uh from Jerusalem you are
witnesses of these things and behold I
am sending the promise of my father upon
you but stay in the city until you're
clothed with power from on high and thus
the reading of God's holy word so
Jeremiah like I said you are a Baptist I
am a presbyterian yet despite our
differences
we are united in the same mission that
Jesus left the apostles with as the Old
Testament foretold of the person and
work of
Jesus which is what the gospel most
specifically is the good news about the
person and work of Jesus who he is and
what he accomplished followed by how you
as a sinner can turn to him and receive
him for the Forgiveness of your sins and
the mission of Christ followers is to
take this message to all Nations tribes
tongues peoples Etc same thing we see in
Matthew 28 with the Great Commission
take the gospel to the Nations baptizing
them in the name of the Triune God
teaching them to obey all that Christ
commanded ultimately the church exists
to one spread the gospel two equip
Believers and three glorify God in all
things all of that is summed up in the
singular Mission Jesus gave the church
now I have a second
question did Jesus leave the church with
multiple missions or just a single
Mission the Great Commission sums it up
and that I I look at it as as two parts
people think that discipleship is
getting somebody in the church to be
baptized and all right we got to rinse
and repeat and it's like the second half
is to teach them to obey all that is
commanded so maybe maybe you can teach
me something here but I mean there's
there's a single-mindedness in the Great
Commission but that covers a multitude
of things that the New Testament tells
us to do so my reason for asking this is
going to become more apparent as we get
further into tonight you're going to see
why I'm asking this because there's a
little bit of nuance here and I want to
clarify so folks the church has one
primary mission to glorify God by making
disciples of Jesus Christ Matthew
28:18-20
however this Mission expresses itself in
multiple
ways including one evangelism so sharing
the gospel with unbelievers Matthew
1615 two discipleship teaching and
equipping Believers to grow in faith
Colossians
1:28 third worship honoring and
glorifying the Triune God in all aspects
of life so John 423- 24 four service and
compassion Mercy if you will meeting
physical spiritual needs so Matthew 25
35-40 five fellowship and community so
encouraging and strengthening the body
of Christ Hebrews 10:2 24-2 is an
example and then six defending the faith
apologetics upholding biblical truth
against false teachings 1 Peter 3:15
Jude 3 Etc so these are not separate
missions but different facets of the one
Mission Christ gave to his church
everything the church does should
ultimately be in harmony
with this so Jesus did not leave the
church with multiple missions he left
one Mission and that single Mission
expresses itself in multiple ways might
be a small Nuance but it's it's an
important one and we're going to see why
shortly anything you'd like to add to
that yeah you had me sweating I was like
did I forget another second mission that
Jesus gave well I'm I'm glad that you
said that because we're going to
transition here now to listening to our
Clips I know that that was a very short
uh lay of the foundation but that's
important before we get into this I want
to listen to Ted Wilson explain the SDA
Church's 13th fundamental belief which
is titled The Remnant and its Mission
okay and we're going to get into this
and we're going to test what he says
against what we just talked about to
examine our uh question of the night if
you will so with that said let's get
into
it of a Remnant appears throughout the
Bible and probably one of the most
well-known stories is that of Noah and
and the Ark it was during a time of
great wickedness as described in Genesis
6:5 and verse 11 then the Lord saw that
the wickedness of man was great in the
earth and that every intent of the
thoughts of his heart was only evil
continually the Earth also was corrupt
before God and the Earth was filled with
violence but we are told in verse 8 Noah
found Grace in the eyes of the
Lord God told Noah of his plan to
destroy the Earth with a flood and
explained there would be a way of Escape
for everyone who chose to accept God's
grace through faith and obedience Noah
was to build an enormous Ark inviting
all to come inside where they would be
safe from the coming
storm for 120 years Noah preached but in
the end only eight people chose to be
saved Noah and his family they were the
remnant in the last days right before
Jesus returns to Earth to take his
followers to Heaven a similar situation
will happen again Jesus tells us in
Matthew chap 24 verse
37 but as the days of Noah were so also
will
the coming of the son of man
be the world will be filled with
wickedness but those who trust and
believe God will remain strong amidst
the world's influence rejecting its
self-serving ways and embracing God's
ways all right so Jeremiah the SDA
Church loves making Noah a type or a
picture of all sorts of things Noah is
supposed to be a picture of the end
times regarding the remnant and
salvation because Jesus says As it was
in the days of Noah so also will co uh
the coming of the son of man be what are
your thoughts on what he said and was
that what Jesus was saying in Matthew
2437 so I was thinking about this
earlier and it's wild that you know I'm
learning from you that this is such a
huge emphasis with the the Adventist so
it's I want I want to say when we look
at the all of it discourse yes at the
coming of the son of man there's going
to be swift judgment I think that is
really what we're supposed to glean from
the times of Noah I mean a lot of people
look at this as a proof text for people
are going to be snatched one left at the
Mill it's like who people people are
going to be smited at the the second
coming of Christ and so that's what's
going on here in the the all of it
discourse as it relates to Noah to go
beyond that is more than what the text
is actually telling us and so as we're
going to continue to hear him talk about
the the word Remnant right remainder uh
essentially those that are called out or
distinguished uh I want us to talk about
the the scripture has a very pointed
definition of what the remnant actually
looked like yeah like I said they they
love to use the story of Noah for all
sorts of things um we're going to see
the the story of Noah mentioned later in
a source that I'm going to bring up um
but I find it somewhat ironic that the
same Ted Wilson like I've shown numerous
times before loves saying that the only
approved hermeneutic of the SDA church
is the historical grammatical method yet
they constantly allegorize historical
events like
Noah basically engaging in the same
allegorical hermeneutic that became
widespread during the Middle Ages it was
obviously around before then with the
likes of expositors like origin and
serel of Alexandria um like the Eastern
fathers um but I just find it somewhat
comical that the SDA church is basically
using the story of Noah the same way
they are only they aren't talking about
the Orthodox church or even the Roman
Catholic Church for that matter um who
who they you know they use the arc as an
example of if you're outside the ark
you're drowning in the water you need to
join their church because their church
is symbolized by the ark and those sorts
of things so all right let's continue
listening to what he
says this end time Remnant is often what
is being referred to when you hear about
the remnant and it is described in our
13th fundamental belief the Remnant and
its Mission The Universal Church is
composed of all who truly believe in
Christ but in the last days a time of
widespread apostasy a Remnant has been
called out to keep the Commandments of
God and the faith of Jesus this Remnant
announces the arrival of the Judgment
hour proclaimed salvation through Christ
and Heralds the approach of his second
Advent
this Proclamation is symbolized by The
Three Angels of Revelation 14 it
coincides with the work of judgment in
heaven and results in a work of
repentance and reform on Earth every
believer is called to have a personal
part in this worldwide
witness you see this fundamental belief
is based solidly on the Bible and you
can read the Bible passages and more
about it at the URL shown
below okay so by based on the bible
Jeremiah you can think of that in the
same way that a movie is based on a true
story it isn't an exact representation
of the history but it uses real
historical events landmarks names Etc to
then present an adaptation of that where
they take Liberty to you know dramatize
things and spice it up for film Etc
because what he's really getting at is
they point to proof texts in the Bible
and then they plug in LG White's
dogmatic assertions about those texts
along with all the fanciful elaborate
extra details that she brings that are
not found in the Bible but before I
break some things down here he read and
gave a small overview of their 13th
fundamental belief titled The Remnant
and its Mission as an outsider looking
in what all did you hear him saying yeah
so the word Remnant is what I'm starting
to hear I'm starting to piece uh uh the
the pieces together I'm starting to see
them come together and saying like the
Seventh Day Adventist Church they are
the remnant and I'm sure he's going to
say we got to join them they're the true
Remnant and we are the ones that maybe
have apostatized and all the other
things and so this sounds real similar
like you were saying earlier for those
cult-like groups that are saying hey you
got to join our church we are the one
true church miles I engage a lot with
the Church of Christ it's a similar
mindset is you got to be baptized in the
one true church of Christ Romans
16:16 uh the Churches of Christ and then
they don't probably greet one another
with the Holy kiss like the verse goes
on to saying but the word Remnant I
would not go to Revelation to build that
Doctrine I do want to do a quick book
plug um our god reigns by uh Sam storms
just a good resource um as we're looking
at the Book of Revelation with the
grammatical Historical Method of
interpretation with the historic
Redemptive understanding that uh the
clearer text give more light than the
unclear text and one of the places we
point to First is saying look Revelation
prophetic apocalyptic literature okay we
we're going to take that genre into
account and so we're talking about the
word Remnant um I know in the clip he
does give a general understanding of the
definition of the word Remnant as
remainder or kind of a a um a part of
the whole but maybe this is a good time
I would say rather than going to
Revelation that's very symbolic and
there's some wonderful truths that you
know exalts Christ as king I would say
in the Book of Romans which is very
clear dactic teaching we see how the
Apostle Paul uses the word Remnant on a
couple different occasions and I want to
say there is a way to know who the
remnant who the elect in the True Church
of God actually is true Saints and so
the verse that you have uh pulled up
here quoting the Old Testament so this
is true Old Testament this is just as
true then as it is today U Isaiah Cries
Out concerning Israel and I just want to
pause earlier in Romans or chapter n not
all Israel physical uh nationalistic
Israel is of the true Israel of God so
Isaiah Cries Out concerning Israel
though the number of the Israelites have
been like the sand of the sea Only The
Remnant will be saved and so we have to
say time out the Apostle Paul has
already been talking about what
salvation looks like justification is by
faith apart from works and so if you do
want to scroll down on the passage look
with me at verse 30 what shall we say
that the Gentiles who did did not pursue
righteousness have attained it that is a
righteousness that is by faith Paul is
echoing the groundwork that he's already
laid earlier in the Book of Romans so
verse 32 why because they did not pursue
it by faith but as if it were on the it
was based on Works he continues to talk
about the true remnant of God are those
that are justified by faith alone but
it's a it's a real Faith it's a heart
that trust in Christ alone all to the
glory of God alone and so what I'm
hearing with the Seventh Adventist
because I've you know looked into them
before is there is a strong emphasis on
keeping the Sabbath and I say time out
that is Law and so if you're saying that
you are the one true church by your
Sabbath keeping and rules I'm like that
is echoing the old Covenant which is a
covenant of works and is a covenant of
condemn a and a covenant of death we are
part of a better Covenant that saves to
the uttermost and it is a like we would
have some shared commonality here we are
saved by a Covenant of Grace not a
covenant of works and so I do want to
just point out one more verse um as
we're looking at Romans look with me at
Romans 11 starting in verse 5 so to at
the present time there is a Remnant okay
but they are chosen by Grace not by
Sabbath lawke keeping but if it is by
Grace it is no longer miles on the basis
of Works otherwise Grace would no Grace
would no longer be grace and so it's an
odd way to say we're the remnant we got
to go to Revelation to build that case
when Paul has been echoing Old Testament
passages showing us that God
isfied by faith alone and Christ alone
and then they live to the glory of
God Amen bro and you you pointed out
something super important there shout
out to Sam storms I love Sam storms um
you pointed out just kind of a
fundamental hermeneutics 101 type thing
which is that the unclear passages do
not Trump when it comes to sound
hermeneutics the clear passages we
interpret the unclear in light of the
clear not the other way around now what
you're going to find in seventh day
adventism is they think the unclear is
crystal clear because The Remnant they
claim that God has given them special
prophetic Insight that no one else has
so it's Crystal Clear to them but then
you'll find that the clear passages are
actually obscure they're really hard to
understand like when Paul says in
Galatians 1 there's only one gospel any
other gospel is cursed by God I've heard
all sorts of of answers to that well
well Paul was trained in in a legal sort
of context and so to understand him is
is really difficult because of his
training and his background and these
sorts of things well I wanted to code
here what all was said by Ted Wilson
because there was a lot and if you were
not trained in the SDA dictionary you're
not going to catch it they mention
Universal Church a Remnant keeping the
Commandments Etc now you're go you you
aren't going to get the gist of that uh
in the clip because the wording of the
fundamental belief is loaded the
investigative judgment was weasel in
there their unlawful use and handling of
the law gets a nod Ellen White gets
nestled in there and a bunch of other
things but
folks let's read this again The
Universal Church is composed of all who
truly believe in Christ but in the last
days a time of widespread apostasy a
Remnant has been called out to keep the
Commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus this Remnant announces the arrival
of the Judgment hour proclaims salvation
through Christ and Heralds the approach
of his second Advent this Proclamation
is symbolized by The Three Angels of re
vation 14 it coincides with the work of
judgment in heaven and results in a work
of repentance and reform on the Earth
every believer is called to have a
personal part in this
worldwide witness and then you get all
their proof text so I want to point out
a couple of things highlighted are
buzzwords or phrases that are loaded in
their system interestingly they're they
almost have a an adaptation of the
visible invisible Church distinction
going on on here The Universal Church is
composed of people like Jeremiah and I
but the Bible allegedly teaches that
there is an end times Remnant called out
from The Universal Church which is in
apostasy AKA We Are Spiritual Babylon
how is this you might ask because we
allegedly don't keep the Ten
Commandments and have the faith of Jesus
by the phrase faith of Jesus they mean
the teachings of Jesus which they assert
to be their entire system of theology as
I'm going to show in a little bit
secondly nestled into the word Remnant
is Ellen White as we will see in a
moment regarding their interpretation of
Revelation 1217 but then we also see the
quote announcement of his judgment hour
which is coming from Revelation 14 as
well as the work of judgment in heaven
aka the investigative judgment and then
the final sentence every believer is
called to come join them and share this
restored faith of Jesus which includes
the investigative judgment but without
even understanding what all is nled
underneath the buzzwords we can clearly
see that the mission of the SDA movement
is different than that of the Christian
Church the Christian church is
supposedly apostate and rejected by God
we need to come out from where we are
and join them as the remnant in their
unique proclamation of a special message
that only they have in fact like we're
going to see part of this unique message
includes the call for Christians to
leave their church and join them as the
remnant that's supposedly there in in
Revelation 14 John was telling his
original audience about protestantism
being apostate and needing to leave your
apostate Protestant church and come join
them now we're going to look at this
more fully in a little bit but I just
wanted to highlight how much is actually
being said that the average person on
the surface is not going to catch all
the nuances of any other thoughts after
hearing that my brother before we keep
listening no that was very good um I
know me and you have talked about the
investigative judgment before and I just
want to remind our audience um what
we're hearing in keeping the
Commandments this is you know totally
going against the the law gospel
distinction um we we keep the
Commandments of God not to be a part of
the remnant or to be saved but because
we are justified by faith alone and
Christ Alone we desire to obey all what
Christ has commanded for us in our
sanctification as we long to be
glorified one day yeah and they're going
to obviously take umbrage with like the
way you worded that because they're
going to try and say well no no we don't
keep the law to be saved and uh a little
bit of a spoiler alert here for folks
who have not seen um I just got done
recording this past week three uh long
discussions with the guys over at
coltish and the investigative judgment
is one of the things that we ended up
talking about and I explain this in more
detail in that discussion but they
affirm what is called covenantal GN
nomism which was uh really popular in
the sort of anti-right New Perspective
on Paul
discussion is that ji by faith but we're
we maintain our right standing by our
works once we're saved bingo bingo
you're in the Covenant by faith through
by grace through faith it's all by Grace
it's all by Grace you're in by grace
through faith but then you're kept by
obedience yeah yeah yeah and they'll
tell you well it's just the fruit of
being saved no this is just a slippery
way you'll hear some SDA theologians use
the language of um you have to meet the
conditions of the Gospel Jesus made
something a possibility because they're
not just synergists they're like
synergists on steroids Ellen White said
for example Jesus opened the door to
salvation but now it made salvation a
possibility but he can really only be a
savior if you Empower him to be a savior
if you come to him and you labor
alongside him and do your part and and
these sorts of things so yeah covenantal
gism folks is the teaching that um
you're in by Grace kept by obedience and
that's ultimately what they're teaching
here and and like you're you're noticing
I could show you a mountain of quotes
where they essentially say the The
Remnant is identified by those who keep
the Commandments and that's what they're
going to point to in the next verse that
we're going to look at in uh the next
clip we're going to play here throughout
history God has always had a remnant of
faithful ones down through the centuries
thousands of Martyrs have sealed their
faith with their blood especially during
the prophetic
1,260 year period known as the Dark
Ages prophecy tells us the same
persecuting power of the dark ages will
rise again as a combined religious and
political power in the last days and
will once again persecute those who will
not bow to its
demands but God has raised up a faithful
last day Remnant people who are
identified in Revelation 12 verse 17 a
fantastic verse I love this verse as
those who keep the Commandments of God
and have the testimony of Jesus Christ
this faithful last day Remnant is not
some exclusive Club every one who loves
the Lord accepts the truth as found in
his word and by God's grace is willing
to follow it fully is welcome to join
God's Remnant
people okay so Jeremiah little bit of a
leadup here and then I'm gonna have a
question for you okay the claim here is
that Revelation 12:17 this is their one
of their favorite proof texts you're
just going to hear this beat to the
ground in adventism that it's supposedly
foretelling of of the time just before
the second coming where God will have a
Remnant people like he did in various
ages past you know with Noah and Elisha
Etc they then state that this Remnant
can be identified as those who are
keeping the Ten Commandments and have
the testimony of Jesus therefore since
the end times began in
1798 and we live past then that means
we're in the last days so we can
identify this remnant of people if we
find the institution that has those two
things I just want to remind people that
the SDA Church claims that Ellen White's
writings are divinely inspired and that
they correct inaccurate interpretations
of the Bible AKA she is supposedly an
infallible
interpreter this looks a lot like
paragraph 100 of the Roman Catholic
catechism which in substance says the
same thing so Ellen White is
functionally though the sole Adventist
magisterium hence why I have
photoshopped a Papal tiara on her head
one of the many things she said
regarding Revelation 12:17 quote and the
dragon was wroth with the woman and went
to make war with the remnant of her seed
which keep the Commandments of God and
have the testimony of Jesus Revelation
12:17 this prophecy points out clearly
that the remnant church WIll acknowledge
God in his law and will have the
prophetic gift obedience to the law of
God and the spirit of Prophecy has
always distinguished the true people of
God and the test is usually given on
present
manifestations close quote in other
words according to her interpretation or
rather application this end times
Remnant can be objectively identified as
the group who one keeps the Ten
Commandments and two possesses the gift
of Prophecy more specifically on that
second point they possess a special
prophetic word from Jesus himself where
he is speaking to their movement through
individual who has the gift of Prophecy
this they claim was manifested in LG
white in her writings Jesus is
supposedly speaking there and they also
keep the Ten Commandments supposedly
since they uphold the fourth Commandment
that everyone else allegedly has
abandoned so my question for you what is
your response going to be to the
Adventist that knocks on your door and
shares this with you in hopes of
compelling you to come join the SDA
Church well I will find a way to talk to
them about the gospel of grace but amen
when they say the grammatical historical
U method interpretation I'm going to say
oh so context matters right oh yes we
love context I'm sure I mean that's what
I hear from the Church of Christ until
we explore these proof texts a little
bit more and then it's usually we got to
go somewhere else and so Revelation
number one apocalyptic prophetic
literature hey we got to interpret it as
such but I will say earlier in chapter
12 uh I believe it's around uh verse 9
where we read about this great dragon
that was thrown down the ancient serpent
who is called the devil and Satan the
deceiver of the whole world as we keep
going back up he was cast out of heaven
so um Satan has been persecuting the
people of God for a long time it didn't
just start with LG Wyatt and those who
remember to keep the Sabbath holy
because I guess we just all forgot no uh
this is a context of spiritual war that
the Saints have always been under
persecution so my first thought if
someone knocks on the door is we're
going to explore
context yeah and so here's the route I
always go just because I don't like
getting into like well I don't agree
with historicism and your sort of school
of prophetic interpretation which is a
whole discussion in and of itself um I
just go along with them and explain you
guys don't keep the
Commandments they have Tunnel Vision on
the fourth Commandment they failed the
test before even getting there because
as you saw when you were with me before
they have a false god the the present
day movement while it has shifted on
their semian roots of the Pioneers they
still have an idol even if it's a
different one than the Pioneers so the
two groups in adventism the pro-
Heavenly Trio and the anti- Heavenly
Trio crowd they're just bickering back
and forth over two Idols so they don't
even make it through the first
commandment but even that should give
give cause for concern they're Alle
allegedly the remnant God raised up to
restore his church yet he used Heretics
that didn't even believe in him to do so
giving a woman in the 19th century all
sorts of Visions on stuff that was in
harmony with the semi arianism of the
movement at the time only to eventually
give her Visions later on that would
contradict those earlier Visions
presenting a different understanding of
God that's in Focus point being even if
we grant their Theory and interpretation
they don't fit the bill for their own
qualification but a second question for
you what would you argue the correct
interpretation and application of
Revelation 12:17 is because that's what
the person who comes and knocks on your
door is going to say well if it's not my
interpretation they kind of just view it
as like well what I'm claiming is just
the default one if if you're going to
say it's not that then prove to me which
what what it's saying yeah well I guess
what I said a second ago is probably
more answering the second question is
expanding on context this is talking
about how uh Satan has been uh primarily
persecuting the church right and so this
gift of Prophecy um man we can talk I I
would want to talk about what it means
to Herald the truth of God but it rests
on those who are truly called out who
are truly set apart and that is by grace
through faith in Christ alone and so
those are deeper presuppositions that I
would press them on and I did want to
Echo something you said just a second
ago I loved what you said basically ask
them how they're doing and keeping those
Ten Commandments right because as they
want to focus in on the fourth well how
are you doing in terms of loving loving
your neighbor right because Jesus gets
to the heart of the law oh I don't do
that perfectly oh so you don't keep the
law well I Repent well do you repent
perfectly well I try my best right I
hope you didn't miss on one of those
sins that you repent to oh well I I just
kind of prayed a general prayer um so I
think to your point is pointing them
back to God and His Perfection we are
called to be holy as he is Holy and we
can't do that that's why I need a
perfect savior but uh these
restorationist groups they are soulless
bootstrap us right they're trying to
earn favor with God or at least to earn
to to stay in the Covenant it's funny
because uh the Church of Christ they
have a five-step formula you got to hear
you gotta you got to uh repent you got
to believe you got to repent you got to
confess and be baptized but the hidden
sixth step is remain faithful in their
particular group and so it's sad because
these restorationist groups are trying
to earn favor with God and keep favor
with God by their good works yeah and
and the Adventists are going to tell you
no it's not to earn anything it's not to
earn anything but I understand this is
another area where the language barrier
is happening it's like what what group
out there that's that teaches Works
based salvation says hey we teach Works
based salvation none of them say that
folks none of of them say that you have
okay go ahead does the Seventh Adventist
use the word obey to kind of cloak works
because with the Church of Christ you
got different kinds of works you got
works of Mosaic law over here oh but
you're obedient Works those are works of
God over here and it's all under the
word obey yep that's exactly what they
do so they they love the word obedience
they typically will say obedience and if
you disagree with them on this it's
interesting because you'll get this snap
response of just immediately it's if you
disagree with what they're saying about
obedience they'll immediately jump to oh
so you're saying you can just live
however you want yeah no that that's not
what I'm saying the problem in Seventh
Day Adventist theology I can't speak as
much the Church of Christ but the
problem in Seventh Day Adventist
theology is they've misplaced obedience
this is a much bigger discussion for
another day um and it's ultimately
because their covenant theology is
Warped it is distorted they don't like
you mentioned earlier they do not
distinguish between law and gospel and
that's ultim coming from the root of
them misunderstanding the proper
understanding of covenant theology and
so they end up mingling the two together
which results in them misplacing
obedience and ascribing to it something
that is not correct obedience is not a
justification retention device obedience
is the fruit of already being justified
um and you'll have good days you'll have
bad days you're going to get some sdas
who are going to tell you they don't sin
anymore um the sort of they they've
bought into this sort of sinless
perfection ISM and as you pointed out um
this is typically at the behest though
of them having a very truncated view of
God's holiness there's not a very strong
emphasis and discussion in seventh day
adventism I'm not saying it's not there
at all but there's a very truncated
understanding of God's holiness and what
the standard really is and it's it's
interesting with those types the the
ones who think they're not sinning
anymore um the standard of of
imperfection is always right just below
wherever they are they're always just
kind of right above wherever it is and
uh it doesn't take very long to start
getting into the sort of like you know a
lot of them will say idolatry if you
bring that up they they they kind of
boil that down to like well I didn't bow
down to a statue today it's like well
did you put anything in your even your
mind above God today were your
priorities out of whack and you put
something before God um that's an idol
um you didn't keep the law perfectly and
they don't really properly understand
the the purpose of the law so um
interesting parallels there between them
and the Church of Christ the
restorationist movement man
yep rather than hiding their faith these
Remnant people are commissioned to share
three vitally important messages with
the entire world these Heavenly Tidings
known as The Three Angels messages are
found in Revelation 14
6-12 and comprise God's answers to the
overwhelming satanic
deceptions that will sweep across the
world just before Christ's
return the Apostle John describes the
first Angel's message like this then I
saw another Angel flying in the midst of
Heaven having the Everlasting gospel to
preach to those who dwell on the earth
to Every Nation tribe tongue and people
saying with a loud voice fear God and
give glory to him for the hour of his
judge judgement has come and worship him
who made Heaven and Earth the sea and
springs of water you see the first Angel
spreads the Everlasting good news that
God is our creator our only source of
Salvation and that we are to worship
only him it also contains wording right
out of the fourth Commandment indicating
that the seventh day is still the day
God has set aside and made holy for
worship another important aspect of this
message is that the hour of his judgment
has come urging a call to True
repentance and
Reformation all right so brother before
unpacking this for both you and the
audience what is revelation 14 6-12
talking about and what would you argue
the text is telling us
about yeah well I'm least glad we start
in verse six because it did mention the
Eternal gospel so I already know if I'm
talking to a Seventh Adventist they just
brought me a verse that talks about the
gospel truly with the good news of how
someone can have their sins forgiven I
think I would spend a lot of time there
and about how that is the remnant out of
every nation tribe uh language and
people so I would talk about there and
then when we get into Babylon the great
uh sure this is um these are the Nations
that are under the um the power of Satan
right and so once again this gets back
into a a bigger discussion want to
recommend this is a commentary on the
Book of Revelation of how we see the
church at war with the kingdom of
darkness and you know who who Reigns
Supreme in his Heavenly Ministry from
above and on high Jesus Christ and so he
protects the true bride the True Church
the true Remnant those that are called
out by grace alone through faith alone
so uh I'm curious to hear some of your
thoughts because you know it's so
interesting I'm used to a different set
of proof texts with baptism right um so
hearing how and it makes sense for you
know a group like the Seventh Day
Adventist to go to the Book of
Revelation because it's like they got to
use the cryptic text to inform you and I
could see the deception with maybe
people that are Evangelical and don't
know a lot of really good theology I
could see how man it says that they're
explaining a lot of things around that
and so it could be really
deceptive that is exactly what happens
and so you mentioned the phrase some
some translations will say the Eternal
gospel you'll hear them use the phrase
Everlasting gospel um and there is a
whole truckload of things that are
trojan horsed into this so I'm excited
now to break this down for you so we're
going to end up tonight folks we're
going to end up going through both the
fir or all uh the first second and third
Angels messages here their
interpretation of Revelation 146 the
first Angel's message changed after the
great disappointment originally it was
said to be foretelling of the millerite
movement and what was proclaimed in 1843
and
44 as the Adventist Pope claims to be
shown in Vision that the prophecy of the
first and second Angels messages was
fulfilled in this disappointment and
heralding of William Miller's message
meaning the Bible allegedly foretold of
the millerite movement and the great
disappointment which is what they claim
Revelation 10 9-11 is also saying but
after the great disappointment most
millerites abandoned this thinking and
rightly so they instead came to believe
that Revelation 14 was describing a
future event yet to be fulfilled to
which Ellen White blasted them and
credited Satan and the Fallen Angels for
for why these individuals adopted that
idea leaving them in darkness she was
also allegedly shown that all of heaven
was filled with indignation over this
and Jesus was slighted by
such now the original understanding of
the millerites was that fear God and
give glory to him for the hour of his
judgment has come was referring to the
Judgment of God upon the wicked which is
generally understandable since the
entire focus of chapter 14 is about the
wrath of God toward the wicked in short
though they believed this text was
saying that God's Wrath toward the
wicked was going to be poured out upon
the Earth in
1844 but since that didn't
happen and some of the millerites
refused to accept that they were wrong
they faced a new
dilemma since the Wrath wasn't poured
out on the wicked in 1844 how could they
continue claiming the first Angel's
message was fulfilled when the Judgment
of the wicked never
happened this was then the Catalyst
leading to their the of the
investigative judgment in heaven so
instead of executing Justice on the
wicked they completely inverted the
focus of the text from being about the
wicked to actually being about a
pre-advent investigative judgment event
that started in heaven not on Earth
where all of those who professed faith
in God all the way back to Adam are
having their life record reviewed to see
who is and isn't worthy of the atoning
benefits of Christ they embraced this
Theory because it allowed them one to
still maintain that judgment began in
1844 and two still be able to assert
that the first two angels messages had
already sounded maintaining what Ellen
White was allegedly shown in Vision thus
they claim this passage is actually for
telling of October 22nd 1844 when the
investigative judgment began in heaven
and that's what the hour of his judgment
has come is supposedly referring to
Jeremiah I don't know why I brought this
slide up because we're not there yet
technically that's okay any thoughts on
all that before we peel back the layers
on this phrase
Everlasting
gospel Everlasting Eternal it's because
there's only one way of Salvation And so
we see about you know an Everlasting
Covenant in the Old Testament scriptures
and you have Old Testament Saints being
justified by faith in the coming Messiah
who um inaugurates by his blood a a
better Covenant and so it is interesting
to me how
some of these phrases and these verses
they just take a little bit and then
just import you know all the bell and G
white interpretation and so it does make
me sad uh but praise be to God that his
gospel is an everlasting gospel because
we have our sins removed as far as the
East is from the West amen so Central to
all of this is like you pointed out and
I said is what they import into that
phrase Everlasting gospel which Ted has
already mentioned numerous times this is
vitally important to flesh out and for
people to understand so folks bear with
me so in the review in Herald which for
those that do not know this is the SDA
Church's worldwide paper we read this
about what they claim the Everlasting
gospel is
quote this movement with which we are
connected stands for certain great
fundamental truths the existence of God
the inspiration of the Holy scriptures
salvation alone through the vicarious
sacrifice of the Lord Jesus repentance
Reg generation and the gift of
righteousness by faith the work of the
Holy Spirit the immutability of God's
law The Binding claims of the Bible
Sabbath the Priestly Ministry of Christ
in the Heavenly Sanctuary the
investigative judgment now going on the
soon coming of Christ to take his
children home the doctrine of spiritual
gifts the manifestation of the gift of
Prophecy in the remnant Church Life only
in Christ Christian Temperance and other
leading important Bible doctrines these
great truths constitute the Everlasting
gospel message for this time to the 7th
Day Adventist Church has been committed
this
message the Everlasting gospel was
preached by Noah by Abraham by Paul and
Peter and by all the prophets and
apostles of past ages it was preached in
the setting appropriate to their
day we cannot preach this gospel message
as Noah preached it or as Paul or Luther
gave it it is for us to preach in this
uh in it is for us to preach it in the
setting of God's Great three-fold
message of Revelation 14 Luther preached
righteousness by faith in the setting of
The Gospel message for the 16th century
we must preach righteousness by faith in
the setting of God's message for this
time we are told by the messenger of the
Lord talking about Ellen White several
have written to me inquiring if the
message of justification by faith is the
third Angel's message and I have
answered it is the third Angel's message
in
it the Apostle Paul preached the
righteousness and Temperance uh or the
Apostle Paul preached of righteousness
and Temperance and of a judgment to come
we cannot preach the Judgment of God as
did the Apostle we must preach the hour
of his judgment is come that judgment is
now going forward the great underlying
principles of these truths are the same
but in our preaching their application
must be made to the present day
conditions close quote so already we
have serious issues we see they claim
that the Everlasting gospel refers
basically to the Seventh Day Adventist
Church's entire system of theology this
is an insight into how when they use the
word
gospel they aren't referring to the
person and work of
Christ they mean seventh day sabari inis
the investigative judgment Ellen White
as a prophet their lifestyle and
Temperance doctrines Etc and all of
those things are essentially dogmas not
merely Doctrine meaning in this model if
you don't believe their system of
theology your soul is in Jeopardy
secondly we see they try and say that
the Everlasting gospel was preached by
people such as Noah Abraham Paul Etc but
it was preached in the setting of their
day so it looked different it can't be
preached the same way today because we
live in a different time and there's a
specific present truth message for this
day and age for example when Paul
preached about a judgment to come
they're claiming they still preach the
same thing he did that there's a
judgment it just looks different because
we live at the end of time and Paul
didn't mil question that's what they
mean by phrases like present truth or or
the truth for this present time go ahead
so Martin Luther's what the the quote
was referring to right when Martin
Luther was preaching yep so he was not
he did not have their view of keeping
the Sabbath so help me understand why
they can put Martin Luther in a positive
life there so this gets into their whole
uh Ellen White's essentially the great
controversy where they've cherry-picked
various people throughout history and
they try to say like well Luther was
right about this and John Calvin was
right about this and this individual was
right about this and we've taken all
these things from all the different
individuals that got one thing right
basically and we are the fullness of all
of those truths together that were
coming out of the Babylonian exile of
the church being in cap captivity which
they try to appeal to Luther on
Etc so Babylon cap captivity are you
either in that captivity and are lost or
are you not like how does that work in
their mind no they're they're appealing
to Luther's understanding of the church
going into captivity so we talked about
this a little bit the last time you were
here basically this idea they they try
and claim that that Paul said in uh
second Thessalonians that there's going
to be this great apostasy which they
basically read into the text the church
is going to die essentially um they they
won't say that it died they'll just if
you ask them to point okay point to me
who was the Christian in the year 600
who who was a Christian in 800 900 it's
going to be these unnamed Fringe pockets
of who knows where and basically the P
the papacy rose up and began persecuting
the church and the church was in
Babylonian captivity for all this time
until basically like Yan hus and the
waldenian ETC which kind of were the
forerunners leading up to really the
Reformation
but the Reformation ended too soon which
needed to lead to a restoration so when
they talk about Luther here and and
preaching righteousness by faith they're
essentially saying that well he had
present truth in his time righteousness
by faith applied a certain way in his
day and he had to preach it a certain
way but we don't live in the same time
frame and the sort of context that he
lived in so we have to preach
righteousness by faith in this present
truth and times
period got it okay well I appreciate you
bringing some clarity on that I will say
I'm trying to get my presb Bros to
reform a little bit more yeah and that's
your anabaptist uh uh roots coming
through there because that was the that
was the claim that that was the claim
from that was that was Thomas moner's
claim to to Luther you're still
basically Roman Catholic and we're like
well yeah we're we're we're reformed
Catholics I realized John Calvin
probably would have been in favor of me
being drowned or something that is true
and I don't necessarily agree with cin
on all that but that's a different
discussion obviously for another day
thankfully we don't live in Geneva but
two years prior in the same
publication speaking about this same
thing they also quot they also wrote
quote the very fact that this Prophecy
of the Three Angels messages covers the
period between 1844 and the end of this
age shows conclusively that this
three-fold message is God's special
message for us at this very hour just as
surely as we are living between 1844 and
the coming of Christ just so surely we
may know that this three-fold message of
Revelation 14 6-12 is God's present
Truth for this present time the time for
this message is very definitively fixed
to the present generation he who will
receive this prophecy as given by Jesus
Christ may be just as sure that this is
Christ's special message for us today as
if Jesus were to appear in person and
speak this three-fold Proclamation with
an audible voice in harmony with this
idea that this message is limited to the
period between 1844 and the end we find
that no one prior to 1844 had ever
claimed to have given this three-fold
message neither Luther nor Calvin not
Knox Wesley Alexander Campbell or any
other of the great lights of those times
set up the claim that they were doing
this predicted work of Revelation 14
6-12 if this work had been done by any
of them they would have surely known it
this prophecy of Revelation 14 6-14 does
not and cannot refer to any proclamation
of the Gospel in the days of the
Apostles the early Christian fathers or
the reformers of the 16th 17th or 18th
century it is strictly a Last Day
message applicable to those who live
just before the return of
Christ close
quote so they understand Revelation 14 6
and 7 and that phrase Everlasting gospel
to be a gospel that wasn't preached by
anyone prior to their movement it's not
Apostolic in origin it wasn't heralded
by the apostles the church fathers it's
strictly a Last Day message which they
claimed the last days began in
1798 yet Paul the Apostle says in
Galatians 1 there's only one gospel any
other so-called gospels cursed by God
and he says it's the gospel that Jesus
himself gave to the apostles and that
has been handed down to us today in
sacred scripture the apostles did not
preach the investigative judgment for
the Forgiveness of sins they didn't
preach get out of the Protestant
churches and join the SDA Church as the
remnant for the Forgiveness of sins Etc
but to defend against this charge they
try and propose like we saw in that last
source that they're not preaching a
gospel that's different than the
apostles it just takes a present truth
form that's applicable to our day very
slippery and deceptive because it is a
different message you don't just get to
say well Paul preached about judgment
and since we do too that means we're
preaching the same message when what
they mean is something entirely foreign
to the apostles wasn't preached by them
and was entirely unknown until their
movement was born out of a false prophet
date setting for the return of Christ
furthermore Paul presents the gospel as
the good news about the person and work
of Jesus not systematic theology
Jeremiah thoughts on any of that before
transitioning to the final Source on
this that will add another problematic
Dimension to all of this quick question
about you know the Eternal gospel where
where's the dividing line for them where
we're not them just saying oh you're
misled and you're misinformed but you're
a part of this universal church for them
like is there a dividing line like if
you don't keep the Sabbath holy are you
lost or or something else I'm going to
leave you on a cliffhanger cuz we're
going to get into that later okay sounds
good so lastly I want to look at some
some of what SDA Theologian Herbert
Douglas said in a paper titled what is
the Everlasting gospel so we can see
another aspect of all of this some
Adventists get hopping mad when I site
Herbert Douglas and they can get over it
Herbert Douglas folks for those that do
not know LED light of the SDA church he
has since pasted hopefully his soul was
in Union with Christ and he is in the
presence of incredible Holiness right
now experiencing ioic Vision that's what
I hope he seemed like a great guy but
what we're about to read here is
seriously problematic he starts out by
saying
quote John the Revelator saw that
sometime before the end of the world
before Jesus returned a movement would
arise having the Everlasting gospel to
preach to those who dwell on the earth
to Every Nation tribe tongue and people
saying with a loud voice fear God and
give glory to him for the hour of his
judgment has come Revelation 14
6-7 that uh those who respond to this
gospel are described in verse 12 as
those who keep the Commandments of God
and the faith of Jesus this Everlasting
gospel focuses on one God to whom
worship and obedience are due and two a
people who give glory to him during the
time of his judgment why is this
emphasis on the Everlasting gospel so
timely so important so
necessary apparently there was something
about the gospel
that had been muted or muddled for some
time before the events seen in
Revelation 14 requiring this special
Heavenly intervention to set matters
right especially at this for uh foretold
time of his
judgment close quote so he's operating
off of faulty
presuppositions which lead to errant
conclusions and they're the same errors
that Ted uh and the fundamental beliefs
book operate on or the fundamental
belief operates on namely that the end
times began in 1798 and Revelation is
for telling of the millerites in the sth
day Adventist movement when the text
says the Everlasting gospel will go to
all tribes tongues peoples and
Nations that's supposed to be talking
about the Adventist system of doctrines
like we read in the review in Herald
what the Christian church is taking to
the world Douglas is going to call a
limited gospel and that's that's
supposedly not what's in Focus here in
Revelation 14 something about the gospel
was allegedly lost between the apostles
to the present day and the text is
telling us that there would need to be a
Heavenly intervention to basically
restore the fullness of the Gospel a few
pages later he also notes quote the
purpose of the Gospel is to make plain
why Jesus came and why he died the
Everlasting gospel in the end times
restores the New Testament gospel in its
wholeness in its Integrity it explains
God's plan to save men and women in such
a way that their presence in the new
Earth would not jeopardize again the
well-being and security of the universe
thus the gospel is not limited to the
good news of his pardon and forgiveness
it presents the ellipse of truth that
reveals the Integrity of God's grace as
including his forgiveness and his power
to transform the Everlasting gospel adds
much more to limited Gospels that Focus
only on one half of the Gospel
ellipse the religion of Christ means
more than the forgiveness of sin it
means taking away our sins and filling
the vacuum with The Graces of the Holy
Spirit it means a heart emptied of self
the glory the fullness the completeness
of the Gospel plan is fulfilled in the
Life his ellipses is not mine so
listening again to Revelation 14 the
Everlasting gospel will get a fair and
full Hearing in the end times
limited gospels that ridicule adherence
to God's expressed will as being outside
of the Gospel will appear inadequate
beside the clear proclamation of the
Everlasting gospel limited gospels that
cry legalism at any attempt to embrace
faithful obedience will be seen as
contrary to the message of New Testament
Grace close quote so brother he
contrasts the gospel
with the Everlasting gospel the gospel
is the person and work of Christ why
Jesus came and why he died which in the
Adventist understanding is informed by
their great controversy worldview and it
distorts what the ACT what the Bible
actually says about both of those
reasons
nevertheless the good news about the
person work of Christ is what
constitutes the gospel the Everlasting
gospel he tells us is a restoration of
the fullness of the truth adds much more
to limited gospels which he says only
capture part of the Gospel of ellipse
the Everlasting gospel is supposedly a
restoration of the idea well it includes
this that justification and
sanctification are not distinct in
separate things in other words if you
don't believe that obedience to God
maintains your peace with him you don't
believe in their two-tiered late
medieval understanding of justification
you have a limited gospel which will be
shown to be inadequate at the end of
time as their unique Everlasting gospel
message goes out to every tribe tongue
people and Nation so it isn't just the
laundry list of doctrines that we saw
them present in the review and Herald
but the Everlasting gospel also
supposedly is a restoration of late
medieval soteriology apparently because
if you point out to them their faulty
understanding of the role that obedience
plays in the life of the believer like I
mentioned earlier you'll be shouted down
as having a limited gospel that's uh you
you know you're decrying legalism and
and these sorts of things so Jeremiah
after seeing these sources what sort of
concerns would you have with all of this
well with it being a wrong gospel it's
it's centered around works it in fact
even though it's giving a lip service T
not but it is a system of legalism now
you referenced how it's you enter in by
Grace but you're you stay in the
Covenant by your works and this cannot
offer true peace right the concept of
shalom a ceas fire and so you know I
love going back to Romans because Romans
decimates cultic groups especially
legalistic groups like Church of Christ
as we're seeing with seventh adventism
Romans 51 I always go back to because it
gives peace to my heart right going back
to the gospel of grace that is eternal
Everlasting because we have our sins no
longer imputed on our account Paul says
therefore since we have been right this
is a past work but now is applied we are
justified by not baptism not our works
not by Sabbath keeping but by faith we
have peace with God through our Lord
Jesus Christ so this brings peace and my
point is if I could you know down the
road disobey uh thwart the you know
God's grip on my soul and go out of the
Covenant of Grace or the Covenant with
God that doesn't give give me peace it
can't it can't fulfill the promise that
that Paul is saying that when you are
when the son has set you uh free then
you are free indeed so my thoughts of
hearing a distinction between the gospel
over here that's kind of limited in
contrast with the Everlasting gospel it
lets me know that they don't understand
the quote unquote First Gospel because
that is the Everlasting gospel because
it brings Everlasting peace and
righteousness so yeah it's wild miles
I've never heard that before um so thank
you yeah so they try to contrast
Revelation 14 as like this different
gospel it's like well it does include
the person and work of Jesus it's so
slippery we had a number of Adventists
this week because a clip went up um
where I was talking about this exact
same subject just kind of some different
aspects of it and I can't tell you how
many SDA said well then tell us what you
believe the Everlasting gospel is of of
Revelation it's the same gospel as
there's only one folks I point them to
an article on our website where I I talk
about this in more detail but it's not
some again this is why I was saying they
have fundamentally flawed
presuppositions they're assuming that
this is some special message post 1798
for a specific select group of people
and Jeremiah you'll you'll be shocked
probably to hear this seventh day
adventism at least on paper is bigger
than both Mormonism and Jehovah's
Witnesses combined they're also far more
International
they love to Bo about this they love to
say well what other group is in over 200
countries worldwide they use that to say
look the remnant's going to be every
trib tongue people and nation and what
other group is in this many
nations so that's supposed to prove that
this Everlasting gospel is is their
message here so yeah something we talked
about maybe a while back is you know
when people look at the the book The
Kingdom of the Cults with Walter Martin
two group groups sth Day Adventist and
the Church of Christ flew under the
radar and so I want people to hear that
there is a deeper level of deception
with these two particular restorationist
groups yeah Martin didn't follow his own
advice and scale the language barrier
and he ended up getting taken to task by
the sdas um who very deceptively um well
kind of a discussion for another day but
you you see toward the end of his life
from the John egerber show that he very
clearly started to realize this
regarding the authority of Ellen White
um and if you guys go and watch that
it's actually on our channel for those
that want to check it out I'm also
grateful that you brought up Romans 5
here this is immediately where I go with
any 7th Day Adventist immediately when
I'm doing one-on-one evangelism with an
SDA the first place I go is Romans 51
and I ask them do you have peace with
God oftentimes I get the snap call of
well yeah and then I ask them what does
that mean to
you and we start getting into what Paul
means because this is coming out of
chapter four where he's talking about
the blessed man who's the blessed man
well he's citing from the Suter it's
David but he also points out Abraham so
these two old Covenant figures right
there we already see Paul clearly didn't
have this idea of present truth well
Paul lived at a different time than
David and Abraham and so he had this
present truth and he had to talk about
justification in his present day no he
didn't do that he says in the New
Covenant in the Covenant of Grace you're
Justified the same way Abraham was
you're the same way any person has
throughout all of Redemptive history so
I always come here because in that
chapter he explains why he is saying
well he explains why the what the
therefore is there for it's because he's
coming out of explaining how the person
who's justified by God and we could get
into what justification is this this
essentially it was Christ
declaring Heraldo kamacha was on here
folks for those that want to go check
that out he was here to talk about
justification specifically and he broke
this down so well that there's not
punctuation in the original Greek
manuscripts we add these sorts of things
for for various reasons but he explains
how what justification is is according
to Paul in chapter 4 is Christ was not
raised for our justification in the
sense that because he was raised oh now
he can justify people that's the sort of
thing that's that's coming through in
SDA theology is Christ had to come and
he had to weave together this robe of
righteousness and these sorts of things
and then he was raised so that he could
justify people but that's not what the
text is saying the text is saying that
Christ raising declared
that
Jeremiah you're Justified miles you're
Justified that's what the raising of
Christ was it was a declaration your
sins are forgiven your sins are forgiven
and that's why you can have peace with
God so now they say um repeat that maybe
again for me that Jesus couldn't justify
until he came in his Earthly Ministry
and was was died suffered died and
resurrected because my point is what do
they do with the earlier part of Romans
4 that talks about how by Abraham's
Faith he believed God and it was counted
legodi he was justified before God so
this gets into a very long discussion
which will probably prompt more uh
questions from you it gets into their
cist ology a little bit but it also gets
into the sort of great controversy story
line you have to understand so Herbert
Douglas mentioned there that the limited
gospel talks about why Jesus came and
what he came to do well they're wrong on
that too they teach that Jesus came
ultimately to vindicate the law from
accusations made by Satan prior to the
Earth's existence that in heaven Jesus
was exalted to be made equal with God
the Father a very contested claim in
advent's circles you'll find various
people on various sides of the aisle
that say no no no and they argue this
but Ellen White claimed in her early
christology back in 19 or 1858 that
Jesus was exalted to be made equal with
God the Father this made Lucifer jealous
so he began rebelling and that's how he
became Satan and so he began attacking
the law The Ten Commandments God's
government these sorts of phrases that
she used and so because of that a great
controversy started it's those Central
claims from that storyline that then
inform everything else in their theology
so why did Jesus come well it was to
vindicate the law of God and demonstrate
to all these watching intelligences on
all these other planets and these other
worlds that are watching in on the world
because now there's seeds of doubt that
have been sowed because of Satan and
God's on trial and he has to vindicate
himself and so the plan that he has
enacted to walk out to do such involved
Jesus coming living a perfectly sinless
life and demonstrating that the law can
be kept he went to the cross and he paid
the penalty for sin which is death and
that demonstrated to all the watching
intelligences humans the beings on other
worlds Fallen Angels the angels that
haven't fallen that the law is fair it
can be kept and that you can keep it too
so because of that they also affirm
kosis the kosis heresy of Philippians 2
that Jesus set his divine nature aside
and he was only a man on Earth Ellen
White claims in the Desire of Ages he
had a sinful nature but he never sinned
which is oxy moronic but he was no
different than we are he had no
advantage over us and so they they claim
that he came to weave together a perfect
robe of righteousness such that he could
then impart that to us now this then
gets into imputation versus impartation
they try to appeal to John Wesley on
this and say that well we're just firmly
in the Methodist tradition and I've
tried to get Lucas CIO on here uh from
uh method Ministries because I want to
talk with him about that and I want to
talk with him about that and say Hey how
do you feel about this group trying to
ride the coattails of your tradition and
try and saddle you all with this mess of
the investigative judgment the great
controversy but nevertheless your your
question maybe we I can bring you back
and we can discuss that a little bit
more it's going to open up a big can of
worms um to to I like how you br back in
my what it's interesting I'll say real
briefly is the same kind of questions
that I asked the Church of Christ I find
myself asking that the Adventist here
and it's it's the same package
with just a little bit different
wrapping because you know our heart is
trying to magnify Jesus Christ but all
these cult groups it's like uh we cling
to Sabbath lawke keeping we we cling to
the Commandment to be baptized and hope
I don't get you in trouble saying this
but the Eastern Orthodox Church they're
saying you got to look to us as being
the one true church there's no salvation
outside the Ark of us in Roman
Catholicism is just another you know bag
packaged a little bit differently and so
the Everlasting gospel is by faith alone
in Christ alone and that's what gives
peace yeah so it's like we would have
you and I would have differences for
example with the Orthodox and the Roman
Catholics on the subjective aspect of
the Gospel the objective aspect is the
detail the death burial resurrection of
Christ Apostles Creed these sorts of
things the subjective component is how
is that now applied to you how does that
now apply to your account that's where
we would differ with them well it's the
same with the seventh
except they're not even correct on the
objective aspect of the Gospel they're
off on both the objective and the
subjective aspect how it's applied to
you is off but also what the message
even is and really they're no different
in this regard from a lot of the
ecclesial groups basically we're the
true church you have to come join us um
you're outside the ark and you're
drowning in the
water let's get back into this we read
the message of the second angel in
Revelation 14:8
and another Angel followed saying
Babylon has fallen has fallen that great
City because she has made all nations
drink of the wine of the wrath of her
fornication The Book of Revelation is
filled with symbols representing real
entities and
events now the second Angel warns that
Babylon the biblical symbol of false
worship and coercion is going to fall
God's judgment is coming it is a plea to
flee the confusion of Babylon and its
false teachings and turn to Christ and
his truth contained in
scripture the second Angel's message
will have increasing relevance as the
end draws near and its message is
repeated in an even stronger way by the
fourth angel of Revelation 18 who cries
mightily with a loud voice pleading for
God's people to come out of
Babylon okay so Revelation 148 Jeremiah
another Adventist shows up at your door
wanting to talk with you about their
so-called gospel message this time they
bring up this text and claim it's
telling us that it's referring to
churches outside of the SDA Church being
apostate and fallen and that God has
raised up the SDA a church to call
people like yourself out of apostasy how
are you going to respond yeah it's
probably going to be similar to earlier
I'm going to ask well how do you know
Babylon is all these things and we're
going to cycle back to this term Remnant
uh the one true church a dis to me
getting them to try to make two
different gospels is exactly the kind of
conversation that I want to have to show
that no there's only been one way to be
reckoned with God and it doesn't matter
how many spous proof texts that they
bring up out of the Book of Revelation
I'll remind them this is a book that
magnifies Christ and shows us that there
is spiritual warfare in the church
always
prevails yeah and just I mean the simple
fact that their interpretation of
Revelation apparently the Book of
Revelation took on some new cryptic
meaning in the 19th century just all of
a sudden it just now has this new like
what did these texts mean to I have for
example Andrew of cesaria commentary on
Revel the earliest commentary of
Revelation that that's known from like
theth Century what what did the Book of
Revelation mean to a peasant Christian
in the 900s what what what does your
interpretation how does that apply to
them it it doesn't so you have to make
some new novel secret understanding in
the 19th century why what what but this
is predicated upon their faulty sort of
Miller idea that at the time of
millerism you have to understand folks
that there were people that they were
were interacting with that were saying
we can't know for for 100% certain that
our understanding of the apocalyptic
passages of scripture are correct
because there's a lot of moving Parts
there's a lot of unknowns and that's
okay it's not the end of the world the
plain didactic portions of scripture are
clear it's okay if there's some parts of
scripture that are difficult Etc they
weren't okay settling for this they had
to have some well we have this special
Insight see no one else can understand
Revelation but God has he rewarded their
Obedience of studying the Bible by
giving them special light and insight
that no one else has and so that is
underg guring the sort of claims that
are going on here they can't really get
away from that but the second Angel's
message in Babylon so let me break this
down so like the first angel I want to
flesh this out more for the audience to
better understand what they all what all
is being claimed here and where exactly
it's coming from because obviously the
biblical text says nothing about
millerism Protestants Etc this is their
interpretation and I'm going to keep
emphasizing this and saying this this is
the Adventist interpretation the text
does not just say this I get so so
annoyed when they'll just try and tell
me they'll cite a proof text and then
just make dogmatic assertions no friend
that's your
interpretation they don't seem to
understand that you're just giving us
your distilled down interpretation of
the text yet you're trying to act like
the text just plainly says this and
we're ignoring it first in the
exposition of their fundamental beliefs
this is from the SDA 7 avist belief
fundamental beliefs book they write
quote in Revelation Babylon is also
known as The Wicked Woman the mother of
harlots and her impure daughters
Revelation
175 it symbolizes all apostate religious
organizations and their leadership
though it refers especially to the great
apostate religious alliance between the
Beast and his image that will bring
about the final crisis described in
Revelation 1331
15-17 the second Angel's message brings
out the universal nature of babylon's
apostasy and her coercive power saying
that she has made all nations drink of
the wine of the wrath of her fornication
the wine of Babylon represents her
heretical teachings Babylon will
pressure the powers of the state to
enforce universally her false religious
teachings and decrees
Babylon Falls because she rejects the
first Angel's message the gospel of
righteousness by faith in the
Creator as during the first few
centuries the Church of Rome apostatized
many Protestants today have departed
from the great Bible truths of the
Reformation this prophecy of babylon's
fall especially Finds Its fulfillment in
the departure of protestantism at large
from the Purity and simplicity of the
Everlasting Gospel of righteousness by
faith that once so powerful impelled the
Reformation close quote now what's
fascinating about that final sentence is
that the doctrines they allege are a
falling away from Bible truth are
doctrines that the first generation
Protestants affirmed such as Sunday as
the Lord's Day literally none of them
were seventh day sabbatarians even
though they've tried rewriting history
to claim that the waldenian were until
John Calvin deceived them nevertheless
they State all of this as fact and it's
because it's what white tells them the
text is
saying again quote or or sorry first the
text obviously says nothing about this
representing Protestants being apostate
and falling away from so-called Bible
truth but it's Ellen White that asserted
Babylon here refers to apostate
Protestants who are supposedly divided
into innumerable sects and they possess
no Unity with one another another
laughable charge considering Jeremiah
and I have far more Unity than the
average Seventh Adventist does with the
people in their own Tri
we've read this quote I don't know how
many times on this platform so people
can pause if you'd like to read
it and it was also Ellen White that
tells them on the next page of the same
book that the Harlot woman of Revelation
175 is Roman Catholicism and her
daughters are us
Protestants now something that's
important to understand is that just
like with their interpretation of the
first Angel's message they had to
reinterpret this as time went on SDA
historian George Knight notes this in
his book seven search for identity the
development of Seventh Day Adventist
beliefs where he writes quote regarding
the second Angel's message of Revelation
148 the sabbatarians referring to the
sabbatarian Adventists or the
sabbatarian millerites continued to
follow the lead of Charles Fitch in
interpreting Babylon as including both
apostate protestantism and Roman
Catholicism as James White put it in
1859 we hesit unhesitatingly apply the
Babylon of the Apocalypse to all corrupt
Christianity corruption as he saw it
involved both a moral fall and the
intermingling of Christian teachings
with non-Christian philosophers such as
the immortality of the soul the latter
left the churches defenseless against
such beliefs as spiritualism Babylon in
short stood for confused churches the
one important line of development set
forth by the sabbatarians in regard to
the second Angel's message was to
conceive of the fall of Babylon as a
two-phase or Progressive Cur
corruption close
quote so the question has to be asked
what does he mean by
development this is the quote that the
fundamental beliefs book is parting when
they said that Babylon Falls because she
rejects the first Angel's message Ellen
White claimed that the second Angel's
message was nearing its conclusion when
the millerites proclaimed the loud cry
during the summer and Autumn of
1844 now pay close attention to how she
describes God's rejection of the
churches in
1844 as the churches refused to receive
the first Angels message they rejected
the light from heaven and fell down uh
fell from the favor of God they trusted
to their own strength and by opposing
the first message placed themselves
where they could not see the light of
the second Angel's message but the
Beloved of God who were oppressed
accepted the message Babylon has fallen
and left the churches uh and left the
churches near the close of the second
Angel's message I saw a great light from
Heaven shining upon the people of God
the Rays of this light seemed bright as
the sun and I heard the voice of the
Angels crying behold the bridegroom
cometh go ye out to meet him close
quote so the rejection of what she's
calling the first Angel's message here
was the rejection of the message of
Jesus's return on October 22nd
1844 yet history shows that they were
entirely Vindicated the people that did
that because it was a deception but God
apparently showed Ellen White that the
churches that rejected their fanaticism
and date setting had been rejected by
him where she writes quote when the
churches scorned the Council of God by
rejecting the Advent message talking
about millerism the Lord rejected them
the first Angel was followed by a second
proclaiming Babylon is Fallen is Fallen
that great City because she made all
nations drink of the wine of the wrath
of her fornication Revelation
148 this message was understood by ad
to be an announcement of the moral fall
of the churches in consequence of the
rejection of the first message the
proclamation Babylon is Fallen was given
in the summer of 1844 and as the
result about 50,000 withdrew from these
churches close quote in fact she claimed
that because of this our churches don't
have faith in God's word we don't love
God and the Holy Spirit has been
withdrawn from us only Adventist love
God have faith in his word and have the
Holy Spirit apparently as she says here
in the story of Redemption on page
366 but wait Dr Knight told us that
there was a development around this
Doctrine right well yes because Ellen
White changed her mind first she said
that the second Angel's message was a
call to leave the churches because they
were morally Fallen due to rejecting
millerism by which she meant they
rejected the belief in the literal
physical Second Coming outright which is
obvious absurd she more than likely
recognized this herself which is why the
second Angel's message then became about
going to church on Sunday and believing
in the immortality of the Soul two
things that weren't even being discussed
when they were heralding the millerite
message before
1844 they cite an article of hers from
the review in Herald in her in their
Bible commentary where they note this
change which is ultimately what Dr
Knight the fundamental beliefs book and
Ted Wilson are all getting at these two
doctrines going to church on Sunday and
the immortality of the Soul are the
false doctrines of Babylon and why God
has rejected us supposedly notice quote
this is from the SDA Bible commentary on
Revelation 18 1:2 this is the same
message that was given by the second
Angel Babylon has fallen because she
made all nations drink of the wine of
the wrath of her fornication what is
that wine her false doctrines she's
given to the world a false Sabbath
instead of the Sabbath of the fourth
Commandment and has repeated the
falsehood that Satan first told to Eve
in Eden the natural immortality of the
Soul many kindered errors she has spread
far and wide teaching for doctrines the
Commandments of men close
quote but fear not because of course
Ellen White claimed to have a defense
and reason for this drastically
different understanding which is that
both the first and second Angels
messages needed repeated and can
apparently take on entirely new meanings
the second go around when things didn't
originally pan out notice that is from
manuscript releases volume
16 quote the whole earth is to be
lighted with the glory of the Lord the
pure in heart shall see God it's those
who are following the lamb uh withs
soever he goeth that he receiveth power
from the angel that came down from
heaven having great power the first
message is to be repeated proclaiming
the second Advent of Christ to our world
the second Angel's message is to be
repeated Babylon the greatest Fallen is
fallen and has become the habitation of
devils and the of every foul spirit and
a cage of every unclean and hateful bird
for all nations have drunk of the wine
of the wrath of her fornication and the
kings of the Earth have committed
fornication with her and the merchants
of the Earth are waxed Rich through the
abundance of her
Delicacies close quote now I get that
the video we listening to is just an
overview of the fundamental belief but
even the exposition of their beliefs
don't explain all of this to people
because they'd obviously rather leave
this part off of their path in the dust
bin of History to be forgotten but we're
supposed to believe that this is what's
going on in Revelation 148 the first
Angel's message is repeated proclaiming
the imminent second coming of Christ
just like the first go around except
wait it's actually about the
investigative judgment to similarly when
the second Angel's message is repeated
the same thing happened now it's
allegedly focused on the Sabbath and the
immortality of the Soul originally
though it was about rejecting the first
message which was believed to be about
Christ's imminent return but according
to Ellen White was truly about the
investigative judgment I am sorry folks
I'm sorry but this is insulting that
they expect us to believe this it is a
total mess of confusion which is rather
ironic considering they also tell us
that Ellen White was supposed to be part
of the Hallmark of them being the
remnant and and distinct from Babylon is
that they're supposed to be United in
ways that the rest of us aren't Ellen
White's function was supposed to be one
of keeping them from being doctrinally
confused like all of us Babylonian
Protestants now Jeremiah I know that
that was a lot but as a pastor what are
your thoughts on all of
this one of my biggest thoughts is when
one person leads a movement or claims
that they have an infallible
interpretation of God's word this is
what you get this is when you have an
infallible magisterium or you have the
Watchtower or you have a living Prophet
like LG white there's no such thing as
studying the scripture looking for
harmony logical consistency it doesn't
matter because one person is is leading
the way and so I just want to encourage
people um if you have a controlling
Source a controlling person or group
that's the the signs of a cult a leader
somebody whose interpretation cannot be
questioned um this is where me and my
would unite greatly on uh the scripture
has to be the sole infallible Authority
in the life of of the Christian we are
to test like what we're doing we're
testing what Ellen White says with the
scriptures like the noble bans we're
we're testing um all things and holding
fast to that which is good which is the
bar of scripture kind of off camera here
uh John 1717 Jesus says father sanctify
them in the truth your word is truth and
so just from a pastoral perspective um
you're bringing out the deception that
creeps into to the church into
communities and leads people astray and
yeah miles it definitely breaks my heart
yeah and this just further proves that
Christians cannot fall for the bait when
this organization tries saying stuff
like no we're Christians just like you
we're on the same team no once again we
see that Christians are not United with
adventism I'm sorry I'm sorry Adventists
are nice people Jeremiah great people
that's why I'm doing this that's why
this exists not because I hate Adventist
I love Adventist I want Adventist to
come know the truth but we need to call
a spade a spade we need to call it as it
is we're supposedly apostate God showed
Ellen White all this you can't just
broad brush that away you can't just
handwave that away this was allegedly
shown to her in Vision she claimed
things like our pastors are deceived by
Satan they're tools of Satan that are
using the Bible to lead people astray
because in these apost State Protestant
churches They Don't Really check the
Bible for themselves they just believe
the Bible as their Pastor tells it to
them which is so ironic considering
that's exactly what adventism is for the
most part it's just repeating the the
system evil angels are masquerading as
Christians in our churches we're worse
than Heathen God hates our prayers
they're an Abomination to him all these
sorts of things yet out the other side
of the mouth it's no no no we're
Christians just like you brother no
we're the enemy in their scope and they
take an entire chapter of scripture
that's about the wicked and apply it to
us don't fall for it
folks the third Angel's message contains
the most solemn warning found in the
Bible saying with a loud voice if anyone
worships the Beast and its image and
receives a mark on his forehead or on
his hand he also will drink the wine of
God's Wrath poured full strength into
the cup of his anger and he will be
tormented with fire and sulfur in the
presence of the Holy Angels and in the
presence of the
Lamb friends this final crisis involves
true and false worship a time is coming
when everyone on Earth will decide
whether they will worship the Beast and
His Image receiving his Mark or will by
the grace of God be true to him
and receive his
seal the proclamation of these very
important messages is the mission of
God's Remnant
people all right so Jeremiah now we get
to one of the SDA Church's favorite
subjects one that they think they have a
bulletproof understanding of the mark of
the beast what Ted presented was rather
General it'll have to do with true and
false worship which will determine if
you're marked or sealed and he said
Revelation 149 is the most solemn
warning in the entire
Bible before we look more closely at the
SDA Church's claims the audience wants
to know what would you posit that the
mark of the beast
is for one I would begin of saying you
don't want to start with that and build
everything on top of it but I would it's
funny because I've changed ecologies
over the years I'll just tell people I
was that U premillennial dispensation
waiting for the Rapture and so it's
funny because I had that kind of answer
where now you know I I look at the Book
of Revelation is kind of you know um
it's rehashing cycles of how the church
is being persecuted and so when I think
about the mark of the beast I'm not for
one taking that hyper literal right um
I'm but I'm thinking about what first
John said how there are already
Antichrist among you those that have
pledged allegiance to Satan you have a
uh you have the mention of the man of
lawlessness in um verse second
Thessalonians in there and so I I don't
claim to know but I I think of being in
a good spot is when you have rejected
the gospel of grace and you have
embraced uh the lies of Satan
ultimately yeah I'm in the uh GK be's
like modified idealism the the school of
like modified idealis M I think that it
it gives the best presentation um that
doesn't fall into either ditch so um the
futurist idea basically devoids the text
from really having any sort of
application to Generations prior to
always the present Generation Um The
historicist View which is essentially
what they're part of does a a similar
thing and then the uh the prist view I
think completely um relegates it to the
past and it doesn't necessarily have a
present-- day application and so I'm I'm
of the opinion opinion that that the
modified idealist understanding uh can
both deal with the the original audience
that John was writing to as well as the
present day that it's essentially um any
person who is um part of the kingdom of
darkness you you don't have now they're
not going to tell you the Seal of God is
the holy spirit like Paul explicitly
says in Ephesians 1113 um but I would
argue that because the seal is the
spirit of God um if you don't have the
spirit of God you by default are part of
the kingdom of darkness and you are
essentially part and marked for that
domain and that's how it can have
application in basically every
generation um it's not just relegated to
some future thing at some point in the
future of like a microchip or you know
all these crazy theories that you'll
oftentimes hear in like the
dispensationalist um schools but let's
talk here about the mark of and the seal
so I can break this down for you and and
you can get a better picture of what all
they're saying here because again he Ram
rotted a lot in there if you understand
the language so to really meaningfully
engage with an Adventist folks on this
subject which is something I see a lot
of people wanting to do it is really
important to understand what all they
are claiming they are not saying I
repeat they are not saying that the mark
of the beast is a present reality
they're not saying it's a present
reality if you say that to an Adventist
they're G to immediately just dismiss
everything else that you have to say
because it's such a basic thing that
they're going to say oh well if you
can't even get that right then I'm it's
not even going to listen to you they
don't believe it's a present reality it
only becomes a present reality once the
image of the Beast becomes a reality
which they claim is a form of apostate
religion that will develop when church
and state unite and enforce a national
Sunday worship and rest
law Ted is simply paraphrasing what the
exposition of their beliefs book says
where they write quote the third Angel's
message proclaims the most solemn and
fearful warning in the Bible it reveals
that those who submit to human authority
in Earth's final crisis will worship the
beast in His image rather than God
during this final Conflict two distinct
classes will develop one class will
Advocate a gospel of human deisings and
will worship the beast in His image
bringing upon themselves the most
Grievous judgments the other class in
Market contrast will live by the true
gospel and keep the Commandments of God
and the faith of Jesus Revelation 14
9-12
the final issue involves true and false
worship the true or when this issue is
clearly brought before the world those
who reject God's Memorial of creatorship
the Bible Sabbath choosing to worship
and honor Sunday in the full knowledge
that it is not God's appointed day for
worship will receive the mark of the
beast this Mark is a mark of
rebellions the Beast claims it its
change of the day of worship ship shows
it Authority even over God's law the
third Angel's message directs the
world's attention to the consequences of
refusing to accept the Everlasting
gospel and God's message of the
restoration of true
worship close quote so they proof text
Revelation 149 just like Ted did
followed by all sorts of grandio
assertions that are supposedly just
plainly there in the text despite the
millerites entirely missing that the
text had the investigative judgment 7th
A7 arianism investigative judgment or I
said that sorry in the immortality of
the Soul Etc but all of this is asserted
dogmatically because Ellen White was
allegedly shown all of this Invision for
starters she arrant claimed that the
pope changed the Sabbath to try and
support this they'll point to various
statements from people like Cardinal
Gibbons who said the Roman Catholic
Church changed the day of worship they
then read into these quotes that they're
saying the pope did this when in
actuality by
the church they mean the apostles
because they believe the apostles were
the first Roman Catholics and they claim
that the first day of worship was
instituted by Jesus who began such with
the apostles who then handed it down to
the present day so she's just
objectively wrong here but that's where
the assertion is coming from that the
Beast claims to change the day of
worship it was Ellen White who claimed
to be shown by God that in the end of
time there will be two classes of people
with the dividing line being the Sabbath
the book doesn't even cite her on this
claim but they always verba they almost
verbatim copy this over from a quote
from great controversy without telling
people again two pages later they almost
cited this exactly verbatim without
noting such she proof text Isaiah 186 or
8:16 to say this proves that the Bible
teaches that the Ten Commandments have a
seal and it's in the fourth Commandment
and when the Sabbath was was uh
fictitiously Changed by the Pope the
Seal of the La was actually taken from
it which is why she also included that
in the duty of the that the duty of the
true Apostles of Jesus is to restore
this seal back to its rightful
position eventually apostate
protestantism and Roman Catholicism will
unite forming what they believe to be
the image of the Beast a church state
union which will legislate that everyone
small great rich and poor will have to
worship and rest on Sundays it is at
this point the mark of the beast will
begin to get
issued this oh sorry I went ahead this
will eventually culminate in all of us
apostate Christians uniting with the
world under a delusion of Satan where
we'll allegedly be blinded by him see
only as he sees and feel as he feels we
will begin oppressing the humble remnant
of Adventists and Crush out their
freedom to worship on
Saturdays so much so that she claimed
the entire world is going to be stirred
with enmity towards Seventh Day
Adventist since us apostates will
allegedly be United with all the
Buddhists and Hindus and Muslims and
atheists we're g to be so hopping mad
that they won't worship on Sundays that
eventually the entire world is gonna
hate
them this is going to lead to supposedly
a death decree going forth where it's
going to be sanctioned to hunt
Adventists down globally and have them
put to death and as you can see the time
of trouble was supposed soon to break
upon them back in 1890 just like it was
present truth to believe such in 1849 as
well which Ellen White also endorsed en
vision and as she notes in that final
sentence here only the Adventists who
keep the law perfectly will stand the
test as Jesus said the entire law is
summarized in love for God and love for
neighbor only those who actually keep
the law perfectly will be able to make
it through the time of trouble and be
saved because as she also claimed a
single spot or stain upon the character
will keep one from receiving the Seal of
God the same thing being said in great
controversy by the way for all the
Adventists that just had an internal
crisis moment and thought that this was
just a one-off claim nope sorry I cite
this all the time she said the condition
that Jesus was in is the identical
condition that you'll need to be found
in if you want to make it through the
time of
trouble which Jeremiah you may not know
this sorry you may not know this but she
claimed that this is because you'll have
to stand before God without a mediator
Jesus will cease being such and if you
aren't sinlessly perfect Satan's going
to get you during the time of trouble
you'll sin you'll have stains on your
character you won't receive the seal Etc
all of that mess is included in their
teaching on this brother what are your
thoughts on all of
that if you don't have a mediator uh a
perfect mediator then you will suffer
the the full just wrath of God on true
Judgment Day so the fact that you're
kind of bringing out that they deny that
Jesus will somehow they'll say that
he'll cease being your mediator that
just that goes against such clear
teaching uh part of Jesus's Heavenly
Ministry now he he is ruling and
reigning now on our behalf interceding
on our behalf before God the father so
when I hear that it just breaks my heart
and it lets me know how much further
outside of the faith that they actually
are and yeah they have to suction off of
true Orthodoxy and like you were saying
earlier and pretend that they are
Christian right but that's just to try
to um get in your ear to kind of
shoehorn all of what Ellen G white's
saying yeah to begin prizz you yeah I
know it's like Hebrews 7 explicitly says
multiple times and the author is citing
from the Suter it's like this was
foretold but long before the New
Testament that Jesus is a priest forever
I mean I've heard so many excuses to
this it's just crazy the mental
gymnastics that they'll go through to
try and uphold this well he'll the
office will be there forever but he
won't be being a mediator I've heard
that I've heard it doesn't say
that I I mean it just it does friend
then then they'll come back with wol if
he's gonna be a mediator forever you're
saying that there's going to be sin
forever because they don't understand
that the mediation of Christ is tied to
the Incarnation it's tied to him being
the God man he's going to forever be the
God man not just that but they also
don't understand that the priesthood of
Christ being after the order of
melchisedek is a simultaneous priest
king role Ellen White claimed to be
shown in Vision that when he ceases
being a mediator he's going to take off
his Priestly garments which are supposed
to symbolize His function as a priest
and he's going to put on his kingly
garments so he'll assume the role of a
king at that point they don't see it as
a simultaneous role again Hebrews 7 is
very clear melchisedec was a priest king
a simultaneous role so they just don't
understand the Incarnation they don't
understand it's it's funny because they
try to claim that Christians don't
actually understand the the Priestly
Ministry of Christ that that Christians
don't understand the Heavenly role of
Christ and part of their Duty in this
present truth restoration of Truth is to
restore the truth about what Christ is
doing up in heaven yet they're
completely off like I said you you'll
notice too that there was no mention of
Ephesians 11133 here when it comes to
the Seal of God even though again this
is another area where it's just the
plain the plain didactic portions of
scripture become obscure you'll get
long- winded hopscotching all over the
biblical text to try and infer that the
fourth Commandment is a seal and that
it's in contrast to the mark of the
beast and so on but Ephesians 1:13
explicitly saying the holy spirit is the
Seal of God oh that's ignored um you
know said to be a second seal on top of
the Sabbath or it's claimed that the
Holy Spirit does the ceiling but isn't
the seal itself despite the text
verbatim saying such but a bonus point
for you because Ted didn't mention
this the third Angel's message of
Revelation 14 also apparently includes
the announcement of the Adventist Health
message and that one needs to adhere to
a plant-based diet she claimed that the
avenus health message is the right arm
of the gospel and that it's a part of
the third Angel's message just as
closely connected with it as the arm and
the hand are from the body quote the
health reform I was shown is a part of
the third Angel's message and is just as
closely connected with it as are the arm
and the hand with the human body I saw
that we as a people must take an
advanced move in this great work
ministers and people must act in concert
God's people are not prepared for the
loud Cry of the third Angel they have a
work to do for M themselves which they
should not leave for God to do for them
he has left this work for them to do it
is an individual work one cannot do it
for another close quote on top of the
fact that she said it Al uh on top of
that fact she also claimed that if you
reject the health message you reject God
because he's the one that revealed the
truth of it quote God gave the light on
health reform and those who reject it re
or those who rejected it rejected God
one and another who who knew better said
it all come uh came from Dr Kellogg and
they made War upon him this had a bad
influence on the doctor he put on the
Cod of irritation and retaliation God
did not want him to stand in the
position of warfare and he does not want
you to stand there close quote so
Jeremiah I'm not sure if you knew that
but the Everlasting gospel also includes
that you need to adopt a plant-based
diet otherwise your soul is at risk oh
my no I didn't know that yeah so this
gets into their idea of well Heaven is a
Return to Eden and Adam and Eve were
only able to eat plants uh and they ate
a plant-based diet and so while you're
on probation now which is a whole
another can of worms um you have to
demonstrate that you can adhere to the
Heavenly diet you know you're going to
be in beatific Vision in the presence of
incredible Holiness and you're going to
be thinking ah man I wish I could eat a
steak it's so unfortunate that I can
only eat vegetables here
yeah God has his children in all
churches but through the remnant church
he proclaims a message that is to
restore his true worship by calling his
people out of apostasy and prepare them
for Christ's return it is only through
God's grace and relying on him that the
remnant can accomplish their god-given
mission you can learn more about God's
Remnant church and its Mission by
visiting the URL at the bottom of the
screen I also encourage you to read the
amazing book The Great controversy which
is available free in multiple languages
at egw writings.
org friends the end is near Jesus is
coming soon now is the time to give our
hearts fully to him and become a part of
God's Remnant people fulfilling the
mission he has called us to do I invite
you to become a part of that mission
today so brother after all you've heard
God has children in all churches even
those Heathen Sunday ones were Satan's
taking over and he's using them as His
pawns what are your thoughts on what he
said in light of everything that we've
looked at tonight it's it's a
contradiction I mean are we in Babylon
or are we not are we a part of a kind of
church but not the one true church what
does that mean like I to me are we
Children of the devil or are we not I
just I don't I don't understand it well
you're in luck because I'm about to
explain it to you so you asked a
question earlier and I said we're GNA
get to that we're now at that part of
the presentation okay sweet so after
everything we've looked at they're still
going to tell you no no no God has
people in all churches
actually Alan white said the majority of
God's people are in other churches we're
not saying we're the only ones that'll
be
saved yeah folks you have to understand
what is meant by this interestingly but
not surprising Ted didn't expound upon
the full scope of what they mean by this
and the evidence for such is on their
own
website on the web page for this
fundamental belief that Ted is
explaining here the remnant and its
mission
which is literally just coming from the
fundamental beliefs book explaining this
fundamental belief they write
quote the Apostle John the last of
Jesus's disciples and the one who wrote
Revelation tells us exactly who Satan
will Target Satan's goal is to harm
those who keep God's Commandments and
believe what Jesus taught but among the
lawlessness of the corrupt World God
will call for his devoted followers to
separate themselves from those who have
rejected him
then I heard another voice from Heaven
saying come out of Babylon my people
lest you take part of her sins lest you
share in her plagues for her sins are
heaped as high as heaven and God has
remembered her iniquities Revelation 18
4-5 those who do not come out of the
wickedness of the world will be subject
to the same fate as Satan utter
destruction God refuses to let sin go on
forever and those who hold on to sin
will have to account for their deeds 2
Corinthians 5:10 close quote so we saw
earlier that Ellen White said the humble
Remnant is going to be attacked by those
evil Wicked Protestants and Catholics
and who will be United with the world
we're going to see as Satan sees feel as
he feels be full of indignation toward
Adventist and we are what Satan is
using to attack the humble Pious Remnant
who keep the law and had this special
prophetic utterance from Jesus Etc if we
don't come join them we're no different
than the Wicked World world and share in
the same fate as Satan utter destruction
they continue quote but God's Remnant
people are not just supposed to hide in
holes as they separate themselves from
The World God has a job for his people
to do a message they will deliver for
many people this message will make the
difference between eternal life with God
and the permanent second death all who
hear it will have to make a single vital
decision
either to follow God or side with Satan
and share his fate close
quote so the remnant isn't supposed to
fear the wicked Christians that they say
will one day hunt them down globally
don't hide in holes God has a special
job and message for them to take to us
apostates upon doing so once a person
hears it they have to make the life or
death decision to either join them which
is equated with serving God or side with
Satan and share in his fate utter
destruction so folks don't fall for Ted
Wilson's posturing here and the sweet
sappy background music God only has
people in other churches in so far as
they haven't heard the SDA message yet
and and need to come join the SDA they
claim the end won't come until their
novel message has gone to the whole
planet every trib tongue people and
Nation because they equate this novel
message with what goes to every tribe
tongue people and Nation not what
Christians are taking to the world and
that really answers uh you know the
question in Focus tonight unfortunately
Christians are not on the same Mission
as the SDA Church they believe they are
called out and separate from the rest of
us they are sharing a different
message at the end of the day the SDA
Church sees their mission as taking
their novel message to the world as
their mission statement plainly says and
now everyone knows what all is being
Trojan horsed into this phrase Three
Angels messages as well as some of the
rocky history surrounding its doctrinal
development the SDA church is here to
get you hooked on Prophecy and make you
feel like you have a special insight
into such let no one else does and it's
this special Gnostic Insight that's
going to bring you closer to God than
all of those Wicked Sunday Christians
out there we just listened to an SDA
Pastor in the members only section on on
the channel who outright said the data
shows that the SDA Church's Evangelistic
efforts are most successful with
evangelicals who already have a bent
towards Bible
prophecy Christians need to understand
that this organization ultimately
considers itself to be distinct and
separate we're Babylon they're
supposedly are the ones keeping the law
Ellen White said they're the
depositories of God's law and in every
generation God has had a people who they
were the depositories of his law and the
s church is that at the end of time they
have a prophet with a special prophetic
word from Jesus that no one else does
and this unique prophetic word is
essentially a restoration of the Full
Gospel the complete gospel the
Everlasting Three Angels messages
present truth only for the end times
gospel that the apostles didn't even
preach we need to be sharing the true
gospel with Seventh Day Adventist folks
lots of them do not like me saying this
and that's fine but again a spade is a
spade Christians have to understand that
behind all of the language is a
different message a different Mission a
different gospel and a different God
Etc which is why the call of this
platform is for Adventists to come out
of her my people there are sheep that
are caught in this movement that the
Triune God is absolutely calling out
they have ears to hear and we trust that
the Lord is a powerful savior not a
potential one and they will be led out
may God use this effort for days weeks
and years to come for the advancement of
his kingdom brother would you mind
closing us out by sharing the gospel It
Be My Honor so the gospel is a
proclamation of good news and so why do
we need good news because we are all
sinners before the one true God who is
Holy Holy Holy and so he will execute
his Justice um on law Breakers and so we
deserve Wrath for our sin because
ultimately all of our sin is aimed
vertical against God The God Who gave
you breath the god that sustains your
life and we've all went astray from
birth we've all sought our own way and
our own devices and we have transgressed
God's perfect law which is holy
righteous and good the book of Acts uh
many individuals asked the questions hey
what s what must I do to be saved saved
from my sin saved from this temporary
world of of Destruction well believe on
the Lord Jesus Christ and you will be
saved when we put our faith in Christ
we're saying a faith plus nothing not
your obedient Works to a a a list of
commands um like the command to be
baptized or to keep the the Sabbath day
holy uh the Sabbath we find in Jesus
Christ he perfectly kept the Sabbath
holy and so the Christians true rest
true shalom
is in Christ who not only suffered and
died on our behalf but he resurrected
the third day and so we celebrate a new
Sabbath in Jesus Christ thank you so
much God bless